foreign
welcome to the Ramsay show oh thank you
it's it's very much an honor um I'll try
to keep it brief my husband is 72 and by
the way George I'm bringing a Lunchable
board with me on Christmas day I was
supposed to bring a charcuterie board
but I've learned the new names they'll
never know the difference
I thought that was great
um anyways my husband's 72 I just got
took a first rmd this year I'm 57. we
have two kids in the University right
now
um and here's my dilemma you were on a
call yesterday with a gal who thought
her her husband felt the cash was just a
mirage or you thought it was a mirage
and I'm kind of in that similar
situation but we were debt free eight
years ago and then we stupidly did the
dumb stupid thing we bought a beach
house in 2020 we have since paid off
more than half of it it was about 650
000 and we've about 390 left and I was
thinking should I just take our cash
which I've been holding on to and I can
can pay off another 300 that leave maybe
about 50 000 in cash
um you know but it's making four percent
that's my main question because with
that gal that called yesterday I think
you were adamant that they pay it off
because it's only making one percent
fitting enough no I wasn't paying off I
wasn't adamant because it was only
making one percent that just made it
even worse
I gotcha but here's the thing a beach
house is a toy and if you can't pay cash
for a toy you shouldn't buy a toy
so pay it off
just pay it off ASAP
don't worry about the you've got other
money what is in your nest egg how much
is in your retirement accounts
um you know retirement just total our
total net worth is like 5
but five and a half million yes okay so
390 000 bucks is nothing
but that includes real estate I'm sorry
Dave that's okay but 390 000 is still
nothing you got you got you have an
emergency fund in addition to the money
in the 300 000 Vanguard account the 350
um I no I do not okay well you need you
need a good emergency fund if you want
to call that 50 000 like you did a few
minutes ago that's fine yeah let's do
that and so throw 300 at it now how
quick can we pay the 90 off do you have
any other cash laying around
um we we well yes and no some you know
we have our five two nines we get cash
full of flow the kids um that's College
we're not messing with that we're not
messing with retirement we're not
messing with college but do you have any
other just miscellaneous cash laying
around
is that that's small it's like 60. the
rest is all in IRAs and 401ks and things
of that nature what's your household
income
um about 400 combined okay
I'll tell you what I would do and you
guys may not be up for this you may want
to do it a little slower than that is
um I would take the 60 and the 350 and I
would pay the house off today that's
going to leave you about 20 000 bucks
laying around but with a four hundred
thousand dollar income you can rebuild
an emergency fund of 50 in just a couple
of months
mm-hmm and you free up the payment on
that vacation home as well which is only
going to catapult you guys even faster
into this process yeah right because the
rentals we only rented eight weeks out
of the year and even that rental income
is like what 45. okay so we'll be
getting that later in the year as well
you didn't buy this for a rental you
bought it because you wanted a beach
house
yes and no I looked at it actually I
looked at it Dave honestly as
a form of oh it's a long-term capital
gain it'll do well that way as an
investment but you didn't buy it for the
rental income beach house rental incomes
a pain in the butt and it's usually it's
99 of the time rationalization
justification for buying something I
just wanted so yeah it's just it's it's
not it's not ugh it just drives you
crazy because it's the place where you
stay and you've got renters in most of
the time it's just bad so yeah pay it
off pay it offer or sell it but pay it
off and it's what I would do and that'll
leave you to see
they'll leave you 20 000 bucks I was
right you have 20 000 bucks left over
and uh then you make 400 and so you put
another 20 000 in another 20 000 in and
you'll have 60 in three months or two
months something like that and you'll
have your emergency fund and uh then if
you're going to buy toys it's fine
you're worth five and a half million
dollars pay cash for them
um he has retirement Accounts at 72 that
you can access without any penalty if
you want to go buy another something for
three hundred thousand dollars that's
fine you can afford it but just take
them of money out of the retirement
account and go do it but I'm not going
to take it out to pay it off in this
case you've got the money you're just
just kind of cleaning up sweeping the
dust out of the corners here well Dave
this is a question the heart of it is
when we get a lot especially now where
interest rates are up on savings
accounts and people go well Dave why
would I pay off my low interest debt
when I can make four percent on my
emergency fund why would I throw savings
and there's a principle underneath it of
when you just look at interest rates
versus freedom and sleeping better and
not having that monthly payment they're
not factoring those pieces of the
equation into it it's just well I can
make five percent here and my interest
is three percent on the debt why would I
do this what do you say because that's
not that's not the only equation that's
a very naive equation uh there's more to
the equation than that there's the uh
the stress and the weight that the debt
represents if it's not a lot of debt
it's not a lot of stress or weight but
it's there the borrower is slave to the
lender there is risk involved that when
you don't have that if it's not a lot of
debt there's not a lot of risk but this
idea that you're just simply comparing
these two interest rates and that that's
the proper mathematical analysis of this
is very naive
because you've left out the the toll on
your relationship you've you know the
weird thing is
somebody worth five and a half million
dollars I'm not saying she would
necessarily do this personally but
here's an example okay
um
I do not have any of our uh second homes
that we rent
they're not owned by you
I own I own a couple of [ __ ] I own lake
house or another house other than the
one I live in okay and I don't rent any
of them ever
you don't have to fool with it I don't
need to and here's what's weird five and
a half million dollar net worth they
don't have to rent that but the reason
they're doing this because they got dead
gun payment and they're trying to figure
out a way that this makes sense
mathematically it's easier to justify
when there's Revenue like this payment
is driving these decisions
and if you don't have any payments
lake house can just sit there it's okay
it's it's a toy it's a small percentage
of my net worth hers is a small
percentage of her net worth and it can
just sit there it's a toy and I don't
have to rent it to somehow
feel like I'm not being wasteful or feel
like because the the stinking debt
starts driving you to do stupid stuff
you wouldn't do otherwise like put
renters in your very nice beach house
you know
um you don't need to and you know if you
need to it's because you got payments
because you did some kind of
mathematical thing and you left out the
fact then that you got to screw with all
this stuff and stuff gets torn up and
where is the cost on your time and on
your emotions where's the cost on a
piece of furniture or a family item that
you left in there and forgot to lock up
before the Airbnb dupers came in there
tore up something you know no thank you
no thank you all that means is you can't
afford it that's all that means and
there's more cost involved than a simple
naive formula of well interest rates you
oh shut up
it's not about it's it there's more to
this in life than that there's more
stress involved there's the physical
toll there's making bad decisions
because you're trying to justify
something mathematically it's all this
stuff involved now worth it